le confinement reste néanmoins la règle
alors que les musulmans débute le
ramadan
dans ce contexte des instructions ont
été données à la police c'est ce qui
ressort de cette note interne à destiné
au policier et du calvados
elle les appelle intervenir uniquement
en cas d'atteinte aux personnes ou
d'atteintes graves aux biens il s'agit
je cite d'éviter qu'un manquement aux
règles de confinement ne dégénère et
provoque un trouble supérieur de
violences urbaines pour gilles sacaze
ans et un cadre du service action de la
dgse
les politiques doivent faire preuve de
responsabilité
tél le maillot défaillance est le
maillon politique c'est à dire que les
forces de l'ordre je ne dis pas que
elles n'ont besoin de rien que tout va
bien qu' il n'y ait pas des choses à
améliorer mais globalement elles sont à
la hauteur
nous on a des forces qui sont capables
de régler ce problème là à condition que
le travail sereinement dans un contexte
politique claire et avec des consignes
claires si on continue à esquiver à
avoir de s'accommoder de loi finalement
il faut dire les choses qui sont reliés
à des contextes voilée à des
particularismes culturels
encore une fois on va la sécession de
nos territoires
je veux dire il faut et aujourd'hui on
est parfaitement capable d'imposer la
loi républicaine partout le tout c'est
d'accepter la confrontation et je dis
bien acceptée je dis pas qu'il faut les
provoquer ou chercher la confrontation
mais en fuyant on ne règlera aucun
problème sur le long terme en fuyant on
permettra peut-être à des gens d'être
réélu on pourra maintenir une fausse
paix civile a encore quelque temps mais
il faut que travailler dans la durée et
que nos politiques fassent preuve de
responsabilité